people will very often try to respond to
you on the level on which you address
them so if you say aren't you wonderful
artist then did my goodness you're
beautiful oh you're so bright people
will try even if they're not they really
will try to lift themselves after that
on the other hand if you say you know
you're a dog you really are so no you'll
never be anybody in fact you're nobody
now and you never have been sooner or
later that person will address will
respond on the level on which he or she
is address he will say figuratively are
literally let me show you where dog is
let me show you where Lowe really is I
will show you that deers try to
introduce courtesy into your speech to
each other you have no idea what it will
do for your brother or sister to whom
you speak and you surely have no idea
what it will do for you it will lift you
up there's a place in you that you must
keep inviolate you must keep it pristine
clean so that nobody has a right to
curse you up treat you badly nobody no
mother father no wife no husband knows
nobody because that may be the place you
go to when you meet God you have to have
a page but they just say stop it back up
you just watched two amazing clips from
Maya Angelou take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]